- HELLO, EVERYONE.
I'M JOSEPH CARMICHAEL.
OTIS IS--WAS MY FATHER.
BUT WE ARE NOT HERE TODAY
TO MOURN HIS DEATH,
BUT TO CELEBRATE HIS LIFE.
WE KNEW OTIS AS A TEACHER,
A COMMUNITY LEADER,
A ROLE MODEL, A HUSBAND,
AND A FATHER.
NOW, I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE NICE
TO SHARE SOMETHING ABOUT HIM
Y'ALL MAY NOT HAVE KNOWN.
WHEN MY FATHER WAS YOUNGER,
HE WAS AN ACTOR
IN HOLLYWOOD.
GOING THROUGH MY DAD'S THINGS,
I FOUND THIS REEL OF HIS WORK
AS AN ACTOR.
I HAVEN'T SEEN IT YET,
BUT I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE FUN TO WATCH,
HERE WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU.
- [gasps]
WHERE ARE MY PIES?
RIBBLES, WHERE ARE THE PIES
I PUT ON MY WINDOWSILL?
- WHY, I DON'T KNOW,
MRS. CARUTHERS.
WHY WOULD ANYONE
WANT TO STEAL
ONE OF YOUR DELICIOUS
BLUEBERRY PIES?
- [snaps]
HEY.
SEE TO IT YOU SHINE
THOSE SHOES UP NICE, BOY.
- YES, SIR,
YOU BEST BE BELIEVING I WILL!
I'LL SHINE YOUR SHOES BLACKER
THAN MY MAMA'S BOOTY.
[all gasp]
[laughs]
[yelling]
OOGA-BOOGA!
OOGA-BOOGA SHOO!
- OH, HELL NO!
- OOGA-BOOGA SHOO!
[yelling]
- IN 1964,
MY FATHER MARCHED
WITH MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.
AND HARRY BELAFONTE
ALONG WITH OTHER RENOWNED
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS.